okay so now I'll show the sort of main
technical result in the talk so I'm
going to be giving a proof of this
switching lemma in terms of size in
terms of the DNF size so as before F
will be a M Clause DNF and so the recall
that Husted switching limb of the
classic switching lemma said that if F
has width K then we we get a bound of
the form order PK to the T so what we're
going to do is similar similar to what
we did with average sensitivity we're
going to replace width with log of size
and at first it's not clear that this
really accomplishes very much you can
use this switching them actually to
prove the same lower bounds for for
parity function but it turns out that
this new there's no analysis of the this
that will show can be extended in
certain interesting ways that the
original switching limit can't so I'll
get to that a bit later so the the proof
of this of this result is it doesn't
you know it's not totally clear to me so
the original one implies this one forty
up to exactly that it applies it for all
T actually well so what if you do random
restriction with like probability 1/2
yeah the problem is that you get some
error term and then you that you're
going to get some error term right well
okay so the probability
let me put let me put a pin in it so it
it even could be the case so in fact I I
can prove this using a combination of
the switching them and the multi
switching limit there are ways to prove
this without this entropy argument the
point is not not not just this bound but
I want to claim that you can do
something more with the proof technique
yeah so okay so the way that the proofs
of the switching gonna work are we
actually construct a decision tree
called a canonical decision tree for F
under any restriction so I mean I'll
define this in in a bit I'm gonna give a
sketch first so we define a particular
decision tree and we show that the
probability that this decision tree has
depth T is bounded by the bound we want
okay and then right so I mean so if the
depth is bigger than T then the depth of
the canonical decision tree is also
going to be bigger than is the minimal
decision tree so that moving this is
enough
so first here's a high-level sketch of
the of the proof of the switching lemma
in fact both past ads and hours okay so
I guess it's conventional to define bad
sub T to be the set of bad restrictions
where this restrictions row such that
this canonical decision tree which I've
yet to define of F under the restriction
row has depth T okay so what we want to
what we want to show is that we want to
bound the probability that the peer and
restriction is in the set bad sub T so
that this isn't most P Times log into
the T okay so the way so I should say
this this version of this proof here is
due to raspberr off with labeling
argument it's a little different from
Hustlas original proof so the idea is
that for each bad restriction we define
an extension which is denoted by Rho
star okay which fixes T additional
variables so everything fixed by Rho is
also fixed by Rho star and gets the same
value but Rho star is going to fix
exactly T extra variables and then we
have the following observation just this
sequence of equalities so this is the
thing we're trying to bound the
probability that the P random
restriction is T bad well we can sum
over all T bad restrictions Rho it's so
probably that RP equals zero now since
Rho star has exactly T additional
variables which are which are fixed then
the the the weight of Rho star is less
than the weight of Rho by precisely this
factor to P over 1 minus P to the T
so we we have the success equality here
and all right we'll rewrite this as
follows let's just take the sum over all
all restrictions Sigma and we'll count
how many times that shows up like this
so we'll take the probability that RP
equals Sigma and then this this term is
being counted this many times the number
of T bad rows such that Rho star equals
Sigma but now we have an expectation
here so let's let's pull this this term
in front we have the sum over all Sigma
the probability RP equals Sigma times
this so this is just the expected so
we're taking the expectation over a
period and restriction of the number of
pre images that RP has under this map
from row to row star very
straightforward manipulations but so
let's just rewrite this here as one line
so without loss of generality we can
assume that you know RP is at most one
half so let's just call this order P to
the T okay so here's what we what we
just showed okay so the name of the game
now is to bound so well here that order
P to the T is already accounted for and
now we just need to bound the expected
number of pre images under this map from
row to row star of a P random
restriction and this actually this part
here won't even depend on the value of P
okay so this is the the main part of the
argument or the remaining part of the
argument is now to show that the
expected number of pre images here is
order log M to the T and the the
argument that we show is going to be
similar to this argument that the
average sensitivity of f is the most
twice the entropy is the first witness
function and as I mentioned before it's
not exactly entropy that we're going to
be dealing with but we're going to be
using Jensen's inequality with respect
to this concave function X maps to 1
over T law natural log of X to the team
so the same the same template is used in
the proof of hostage switching lemma so
in the case where F has width k then we
bound this expectation in a very strong
way so well then what you can show is
that this map from row to row star to
the extended restrictions is order K to
the t21
so every single restriction Sigma has at
most order K to the T preimages under
this extension map well therefore this
expectation is at most order K to the T
and then and then one has a desired
bound okay so in our setting we can't we
can't bound the maximum of this over all
values of RP but we but we can bound the
expectation no no I haven't yeah I
haven't defined it will actually yeah so
right so so so a lot of this will look
familiar
so I've yet to define this and and I've
yet to define this extension so let me
do that next
so again we have our DNF and let me now
denote this the set of variables of the
elf clause by VL here's the definition
of the canonical decision tree which I
expect well if you've seen the proof of
hostel switching remover for than you
you've seen this so okay so there's some
cases so first if any clause becomes
satisfied by the restriction row so row
fixes all of the variables and sets them
to the to the appropriate value if any
clause is satisfied then we just output
one I mean the decision tree is just a
constant one and if all clauses are
falsified by row okay every clause is
forced to 0 by Rho then we just output 0
so in the interesting case if neither of
these holds then we let's let L be the
first clause in the for the index of the
first relevant clause so CL which is not
by relevant I mean the first clause that
is not forced to 0 1 under row I'll
refer to this is relevant clause you can
see already this is look looks like the
first witness function in some sense we
let s denote the number of surviving
variables of the clause of the elf
clause under the restriction row ok and
because this is not forced by Rho
there's at least one surviving variable
now let me denote by Q the set of
surviving variables so it's it's it's a
an S element subset of VL of the
variables of lsq and then finally so
what do we do in the decision tree now
what we're going to do is we're going to
query all of the variables of Q okay in
order okay not adaptive but just query
them all and we receive some answers in
the decision tree and I'll denote this
by a and we can we can represent a by a
you know length s of zeros and ones so
the answers to the queries
and then we sorta defined by by by
recursion then we can we proceed as the
canonical decision tree of F under an
extension of row we will we take row and
then we we tack on to it the the
restriction which variables and q get
answers a so to see that this uh
that this is well-defined note that not
that the elf Clause is clearly forced to
0 or 1 under this extended restriction
since we've now set all of its its
variables so therefore this this process
of must eventually terminate so the next
relevant clause and this process will
always be greater than now I should say
I'm going to give this definition and
then I'm going to illustrate it by an
example so so now for each branch in the
canonical decision tree if we think of
an entire branch in the canonical
decision tree which has length T so
let's see it makes T total queries then
it's characterized by the following data
ok I will call this the the branch data
for the particular range of the
canonical decision tree so let me not
denote by are the number of relevant
clauses in this process there's a number
of clauses that come up in the recursive
calls that you will then because each I
mean each relevant Clause makes at least
one query so R is between 1 and T and I
let L for each i from 1 to R I let Li be
the index or the location so L for
location of the I threal event clause
and note that this is an increasing
sequence ok L 1 to L R is some
increasing sequence between 1 and M
before we you know si is the number of
variables that are queried from from the
else clause from the L ice Clause UI is
the set of variables crude from the LIF
clause
and I'm going to claim that it's a
subset not just the VL I choose s but
actually a VL I - all of variables in
the proceeding clauses and a sub I is
the answers to queries Qi yeah right
right exactly yeah and actually I hear
that good there's a typo here already
this should be row Union this good so
right and just to clarify what what
exactly are the queried variables from
the clause CLI well this is going to be
the surviving variables of this clause
under this should they should say row
Union the theories and answers from the
previous steps and right and the
observation the important observation is
that these these lie in all of these
queries lie in the variables of the
Allied clause which are disjoint from
the previous variable since all of those
get set and get together with a row okay
one final definition before illustrate
with an example so so what is this map
this extended restriction so for each
for each key bad restriction rows as
opposed
rich teenage restriction row I'm gonna
make some rows star which has T
additional queries so here's how we
define this so we have the canonical
decision tree and let's consider the
data associated with the longest branch
in this canonical decision tree you know
just for short I'll abbreviate this by
by the vector of ELLs s is Q's and A's
okay and yeah let's assume this has
language playing of T so then we define
Rho star as Rho together with the
following restriction so we're going to
set the variables in these queries the
set of queries Q 1 to Q all are but we
don't set them with the answers under
the longest path rather we we're going
to set them with the unique answers to
these queries which are consistent with
the clause which agree with the sign of
the of the variable in this clause yeah
yeah I'm abusing that Yeah right
people's right maybe conjunctive clause
right it would be more standard to call
these terms so I'm gonna illustrate what
this may be let me illustrate by an
example here okay so this okay so here's
our here's our D NF happens to be a 3 D
NF let's say that our restriction is
this row here okay so it just fixes two
variables in this case X 1 X 2 1 X 4 is
fixed to 0 so the the extension row star
is going to be row together with some
other stuff so let's see how that's
formed so okay so first of all right
when we apply row then it fixes some of
these variables begin value 0 1 and now
no clause is satisfied completely
satisfied here so the process is
non-trivial some of the clauses however
get falsified so we'll just we can kind
of ignore those and then in the
canonical decision we find the first
relevant clause okay and in this case
the the right so the first relevant
clause is is the first clause so L 1 is
1 and there are two surviving variables
there okay the set of those variables is
X 2 and X 3 and now the way we form Rho
star is we you know we query these
variables and we we follow the answers
on the longest path okay so let's say
that those happen to be you know set X
to gets 1 and X 3 gets 1 so I mean note
that 1 when we substitute these here
then this becomes falsified but when
we're building the extended restriction
Rho star we're going to look at a 1 star
so we look going to assign the same
variables but we're going to assign them
in the unique way that satisfies this
this first clause so that that that
would mean we're setting X 2 to 1 and X
3 to 0 and so when we're constructing
this extended restriction Rho star now
looks like looks like this
is it other questions about this example
so far let's take this one more step so
now now we can kind of forget about this
a 1-star and we're gonna now it's an
extended row according to the to the
long path so we now set q1 according to
a 1 ok so now we get a 1 here a 0 here
and so on and this ends up killing on
okay now this Clause is falsified again
no clause is satisfied so the process
continues and we find the net you know
we find again the the next relevant
clause in this case it's this this one
here and ok so the second relevant
clause is the third clause so L 2 is 3
and the number of surviving variables is
just 1 instead of surviving variables
just X 5 and in the long path let's say
X 5 gets set to 0 this will be falsified
but a 2 star sets X 5 to 1 in order to
make this satisfied we add that to our
long path and the process continues
so hopefully your this helps internalize
this notation a bit so we've defined
canonical decision tree and we've
defined the extension of Rho so Rho star
is Rho together with the assignment to
the queried variables which satisfies
the relevant clauses so here's a kind of
key observation and after this
observation we are almost done with the
proof of hostel switching lemma and then
we're gonna add a coda to that so this
is sort of the decoding step in there in
brothers so the observation is that if
if given knowledge of Rho star so if I
give you Rho star as assets I do you
know you don't know which part is a row
in which part is this just give you Rho
star and I'll give you this this branch
data okay just the the number of you
know the number of queries the set of
queries and the answers then given
knowledge of this and of course
knowledge of F you we can recover both
the restriction row as well as the
relevant Clause indices L okay and we
can do this as follows here's an
algorithm if you will for recovering
this from from this well so well we
observed the following I mean so there's
some first relevant Clause l1 and in
order for that to be the relevant clause
it means that all the previous clause is
under under this row under row were zero
and since of row stars an extension of
row than these remain zero and then by
construction of the row star this Clause
is satisfied under those
so we can to discover the first relevant
clause index we just look for the first
clause which is satisfied under real
star so great we've learned l1 at this
point and now we already knew we know Q
1 and a 1 so now we can modify rows star
by overwriting overwriting the values
that set to q1 overriding them from a 1
star to a 1 to the actual values on the
long path and then we can observe that
the next relevant clause index l2 you
know so the this will be the first
clause which is satisfied under row star
of you know this modified rows star
everything between l1 and that will be 0
and this is you know this is this sort
of continues then then you know
eventually in the final step you know
we've learned we've learned l1 to L R
minus 1 and learned these guys so we can
undo this this is l is the key missing
information otherwise that won't be
trivial given row star and SL u a
hospital to recover room yes okay good
yeah right yeah so the way the way I've
stated this so I've defined q here that
it will be convenient in a moment that
you know he was actually the set of
variables so so the next observation I
didn't include this on the slide but the
key point here is that we don't actually
need to know the set Q the set of
variables so recall that you know well
the each each each Qi is a subset of the
the Li choose si but it's enough
actually if I if I only tell you Hugh I
prime okay which is an element of
numbers one two suppose I don't tell you
actually what the variables area is
Madhu points out I didn't need a I
didn't need to do all this to recover to
recover a row right I could simply
overwrite you know the Q's with a since
I gave you the Q's amazed but if I don't
give you the the Q's I instead give you
a Qi Prime which just tells you the
location within the clause of the of the
then you need to actually discover sort
of what is what the clause Li is first
and then you can figure out what these
variables are okay right that's the next
the observation in the hostage switching
lemma right so the I mean it's what this
observation tells us is that well so
this map from row to row star together
with this partial data is is one to one
you can you can recover row from these
guys here and in fact what this
observation is showing is that even this
map row star s Q prime a even this map
is one to one okay and now if we just
wanted to prove hostage switching lemma
well then if assume that assume that F
has width K so so each of these you know
this is a in that case we can bound this
simply by K and then the point is that
the the possible data here if row is T
bad then the possible data here well the
number of choices is only order K to the
T so that so therefore the map from row
to row star
that case is order K to the t21 and
that's that right there is the QED for
hostas okay okay so we're gonna okay but
but in our in our setting we can't bound
the number of possible values here so
we're gonna do something a little bit
different so good so here's the here's
the key claim that we need to prove
right so the expected number of free
images under this map is order log n to
the T so it'll just be nice and let me
let me let I'll let Sigma be old Sigma
is our PV enter restriction so we're
looking at this expectation here and
because this map was one-to-one I mean
this is we can take a sum over all of
the possible encoding data for branches
of length T of the probability that
there exists some T bad restriction Rho
where Rho star equals Sigma with this
data but as we saw as we saw before that
whenever this holds then this holds okay
so whenever whenever you know Rho star
equals Sigma with this data that means
we can recover the outside we can
recover a row and in this way so you
know so we have a sum over all of the
encoding data for branches of length T
of the following event right that that
you know looks like the you know what
happens when we try to decode
so we're going to now simplify this a
little bit so we have like you know that
we're summing over four four types of
data here so let's let's pull out the
you know so these s is form a partition
of T and these this a all together is a
sequence of length T like this so let's
let's just a split apart this this a
summation here this
crying prime is just you know copying
this information here all right and
let's replace this summation with just a
max and the point is that the number of
partitions integer partitions of T you
know that most two to the t minus one
and there two to the T a so okay we pick
up a factor of four to the T and we
don't care about that since we it just
goes into the Big O here so let's ignore
that and just focus on this part so we
fixed some part you fixed an arbitrary
partition of T and we fixed an arbitrary
answer sequence and now we're trying to
you know it suffice is now to bound the
summation over ELLs and Q's of this
event here so that this is at most order
log n to the T and we're done so we now
observe that you know for any given
choice of the LS l 1 to L are the number
of possible choices for the queries is
is bounded by this so you know we have
we have we're taking an S one size
subset of the the variables that one and
so on okay so this is certainly bounded
by the number of T element subsets of
the Union of the l1 to VLR and then just
by standard bound for binomial
coefficients this is at most e times the
size of this set over T raised to the
power T okay so if we for any given ELLs
the number of choices for Q's is looks
like this so let's just plug that into
the thing we're trying to bound so we
have a sum over L and now we have the
max over Q of the of the number of
possible Q of this
and now we're gonna do you know now that
sort of subtle step in the proof I mean
I want to switch I want to switch the
human they'll usually you know you you
know one can do something like this but
uh it's okay to make this too rigorous
now we'll let our Q range over functions
okay so you know Qi now will assign for
every possible choice of indices l1 to
Li it will take some subset there
otherwise it doesn't make sense because
the Q's depend on the ELLs okay so you
just make them functions and you can
switch these like this now this is nice
because now this lets us now fix a
choice of those functions an arbitrary
choice of those functions now we have
two bound finally we're down to bounding
something which is just a sum over the
elves over the sequences of relevant
clause and disease okay and we have this
and now we can observe the following
that so these events here in these these
are mutually exclusive over the possible
choices of the clause in disease
observation and you can sort of see this
as the best way to see this is by
thinking of this sort of algorithmically
that you know so for any Sigma I claim
there's a unique sequence of ELLs which
makes this or and most one sequence of
ELLs which makes this true right you
simple clearly that you just you know
everyone is just the first one where
this this is satisfied and now we take
q1 of that l1 and l2 and so on yes
exactly so we're using we're using
exactly that that observation yeah okay
so the some of these other point is that
the sum of these probabilities over the
ELLs if we drop this this this factor
here then this sum is at most one
now I'm gonna do something looks a
little weird I'm just gonna rewrite this
okay this e times the size of this set
to the T I'll just rewrite this as
follows I mean I'm gonna pull this e to
the T out front and I'm gonna I'm gonna
write the size of this set as you know
log team to the size of the set why do I
do this because the point is that this
here so X maps to natural log of x over
T to the T this is a concave function
that's sort of a lie you should have a
plus one here but I'll ignore that so we
essentially have some expectation of a
concave function and and here's where
Jensen's inequality comes in so we can
we can pull this probability inside here
so so we get that this is bounded by
this here okay so have some factor you
know constant to the T then one over T
log of now we have this expectation to
the T so now we're looking at what we're
looking at sort of the expected value of
this thing here and now the next the
next observation is that so this
probability that is this probability
here I claim that this is at most two to
the you know 1/2 to the size of this set
so I claim that these are gonna cancel
two to one let me just show that on one
slide here so this I'm just going to
show this over here so here's what this
probability is now I'm just gonna forget
about the forget about all these events
that setting that these things to zero
we'll just look at the ones here whoops
this clause is one this clause under
this modification set to one and so on
and if you just sort of squint at it you
see that this is precisely saying that
the following big clause okay so it's
just take the conjunction of the clause
CL 1 and then CL 2 where we modify Q 1
by a 1 and so on this big Clause is
satisfied by Sigma that's what the
conjunction of these
now this this here is a is a clause the
set of variables here is the union of
the set of variables of the Ciel's
and so the probability that so if this
is satisfiable then the probability and
this probability equals two to the you
know 1/2 to the size of the set if it's
unsatisfiable zero but in either case we
get this bound okay because that you
have is this big expression we should we
just think of it as there's some random
you can think of it that way we're now
saying okay so which is where you get
this Jensen's exactly and it's sort of
like right and and if you will it's sort
of like the first right so we can
actually get a kind of function from
Sigma to some sequence of L's and this
plays the role of like the first witness
function
now we're pretty much done I mean just a
small calculation here okay so we were
left we found this
now we showed that this that these
things multiply to 1 okay now we simply
recall I mean how many possibilities are
there for the ELLs well I guess that
should be M choose R right so this is
precisely em shoes are the number of
relevant clauses is and most the number
of variables so M choose R is at most M
to the T okay and now finally this T
pulls out and cancels this one here and
then we're left with this is exactly II
times log M to the T a short calculation
and right now and you know we we
incurred earlier we incurred a factor of
4 to the T so altogether we get to the
expected number of preimages under this
map is bounded by 4 year all M to the T
and then as we saw at the beginning this
implies
so right I mean I if you have if you
haven't seen proof of hostel switching
limo before
imagine many of you might have gotten
lost but hopefully if you look back on
the slides it should be easy to follow
two hours away you can just go back a
few slides and tell us Bayless the first
time we use the fact that you know where
is this parameter T coming in yeah I
mean it comes in a number of places
right so that what are you using so
you're using the fact that rose and back
T thanks can you tell us where are you
using the fact that rose and bactine
okay if Rho is in bad T so this this I
mean this summation here is only over
encoding data for four branches of
length T that's where it's coming in
so you need to know that there is at
least one branch of length T yes so this
is the first time under eyes this
expectation in all the previous yeah
it's just a maximum so we're replacing a
maximum with an expectation right and
let me acknowledge that so actually this
is this version of the results of
speaking in terms of the expected number
of pre images under this map this this
was pointed out to me by by Shrikant and
some of his his students I mean I I
wrote up exact essentially the same
proof but without this is a nicer way of
saying what what I was saying yeah okay
so right so the reason I wanted to show
this to you is because it actually leads
to something something needed it leads
to sort of a unit switching on which
unifies that's been done recently let me
let me let me tell you now about some
some more recent developments in circuit
complexity using what are called multi
switching lemmas okay so so a few years
ago hast ad you know answered one of the
you know open questions and an AC 0 to
give giving optimal correlation bounds
for AC 0 circuits with parity so if you
just apply the switching lame' you get
something something which is much weaker
here so so the optimal correlation
bounds look look like this precise
statement doesn't doesn't matter exactly
so what I want to mention is that the
proof of this is via a different kind of
switching lemma which is looking at
multiple DNFs at once I'll call this a
multi switching lemma and another
development was getting a sort of
optimal algorithm for counting the
number of satisfying assignments to ec0
circuits so this is a paper of in PubMed
so Matthews in pottery where they give
an algorithm running in time 2 to the 1
minus epsilon an for
is Epsilon and this is via a similar
multi switching limo which is
independently discovered the final
result I wanted to mention a very nice
paper of Avishai is using using actually
hostiles multi switching lemma to prove
the you know really tight bounds on the
Fourier spectrum and the Fourier
sparsity of AC zero circuits and all
right so we have we have so these sort
of recent related developments and what
I want to point out is that so all of
these results actually follow from a
bound on a parameter of boolean
functions which I'll call criticality so
this is right so so I'm going to give a
definition here which is very very
natural I don't know if it's I mean it's
something which deserves a name and I'm
not sure that it's been given a name
before so we'll say that a boolean
function f is lambda critical for some
from some real lambda at least one if it
has this switching lemma type bound
that's the probability that the decision
tree depth of F under appear in and
restriction is at least being at least T
is at most P lambda to the T for all P
and T just give this the name lambda
criticality
okay so criticality is the is the
minimum lambda such that f is
so I mean so for example it's easy to
show every end variable function is any
critical one can also show every depth K
decision tree is K critical the hostel
switching lemma shows every KD n F is 5
K critical and we just showed that every
M you know size MD NF is order log M
critical so here's the observation why
is this why is this concept nice well
the observation is that if you have a
boolean function on n variables which is
lambda critical then you have a bound on
the decision tree size of the function
so not the decision tree depth but the
decision tree sighs it's like lame you
get the following bound you know order
of 2 to the N minus and over to lambda
and the reason that why is this nice
because well if you have upper bounds on
criticality then intuitively this is
giving you randomized you know
randomized constructions of decision
trees of and if you have a decision tree
for a function you can easily count the
number of satisfying assignments so so
the observation is that from bound on
criticality you get sharp set algorithms
in a very natural way it's randomized
well you'll see why in a second but just
I'll explain the proof of this you have
to actually find the decision tree ok
yes right so just in a few words how can
you see that this is why should you
believe this is true well ok you know
query all variables from a random set so
we here's a this random decision tree
which will have this size query all
variables from a random set of size 1
minus P n where P is okay just a little
bit smaller than lambda I know the
observation is the you know if you take
a uniform random branch in this Oracle
decision tree then it is just a period
of restriction and now the the critic
you know the assumption that F is lambda
critical implies that the expected
decision tree size of this
cause them so by having a exponential
tailbone on the decision tree depth you
get an expected this entry size is that
most constant so no you just you know if
you just look at all the decision tree
you get at the bottom then an
expectation the size is just it's just a
constant larger than 2 to the 1 minus BN
ok so the propositions yeah right so
there's a very related notion to what I
call criticality which shows up in avi
shai's work I guess you call it what a
switching lemma like property or
something but let me call it degree
criticality so if we modify the
definition of criticality by speaking
about degree instead of instead of
decision tree depth then we can call
this degree criticality and we can
observe that if a functions lambda
critical then it's also lambda degree
critical simply because the degree of a
boolean functions is by the decision
tree depth and now what offish I showed
is that so there are two results in this
paper so one is using the switching Lama
together with multi switching level you
shows that ac0 circuits of depth D plus
1 in size s have degree criticality
order log s to the D and he also shows
that ok if you have any lambda degree
critical function then you get these
nice element type bounds on the Fourier
spectrum as well as bounds on on the
Fourier sparsity and I'm not gonna I
won't say it there's no time to say
anything about what these mean they'd I
think this this one here at least shows
up in the very nice result on on vqv
right yes and we are and moreover this
first one is equivalent to degree
criticality that's another result
okay so can we strengthen Avishai as
result by proving the same bound on
criticality and the answer is yes you
can actually show that using both
switching lemma and multi switching
lemma you can show the similar bound for
criticality okay and you know from this
as we noted that this implies bounds on
the on the decision tree size and sat
algorithm and so on so this is really
sort of a single result which is telling
us almost you know many things that we
know about a c0 I'm not going to say
what it is I'll just say something about
it
the relevant point about it right here
okay so that the proof of this has two
parts so we need to show a certain tail
bound holds for all T and to show it for
for small T when T is less than log ass
then you show it via the switching lemma
in the usual way and the way I showed
earlier in the talk and you know we get
some kind of error term that that's from
this accumulation of failure
probabilities at the switching fails at
simply and that looks like you know one
over poly ass okay and and the point is
that you know this this dominates this
for small T so you get the desired bound
the multi switching lemma does something
a little bit different and it picks up a
factor of s multiplicatively here and so
this one is turns out to be good
precisely when T is bigger than log s
and so the these to cover all possible T
and give you the result in criticality
okay and actually this is what you
really need to have the sad sharp side
algorithms okay so here's a open
question that I wanted to to mention and
hopefully we can you know I'd love to
see this solve this this this term okay
one strengthen all these results by
proving an even sharper bound on the
criticality of AC zero formulas right so
call she like circuits so the natural
conjecture is that the criticality of AC
zero formulas looks like order log as
over D to the D and this would imply the
order log S to the D bound for
circuits now this stopping time
technique which I mentioned in the first
part of the talk similar to the you know
ha stop switching like it's giving you
the desired bound when T is less than
log s but unfortunately it doesn't it
doesn't give you the what you need when
T is bigger than log s and I don't know
how to show this ok maybe by some
combination of stopping time with other
stuff I'm not sure but this is this is
nice and if one could show this that you
know you'd have a again a result which
is not only unifying the previous
results that I mentioned but also the
formula lower bounds for parity but I
was able to show something yeah so
you're saying this bar in play previous
circuits yeah so let's see what I said
that right so this bound here really you
can you can derive from it these three
results you can't derive from it the
lower bounds on the formula size or
average sensitivity of AC zero formulas
so but if you could prove this then
you'd be getting everything so I was
able to do show something using actually
this new switching lemma argument which
I showed okay so it's halfway between
circuits and formulas ok so I was able
to get the desired bound for the class
of regular AC 0 formulas so if you have
the same fan and within each layer then
we get this bound here ok
it's right and and more interesting than
the result itself I think is the proof
technique which is taking this this
entropy style proof of switching lemma
and finding an interesting application
of it so right so as I said the proofs
based on this analysis of switching limo
with log size in place of width and the
the big advantage here this allows a
different style of induction and in
particularly you don't have this
accumulation of failure probability you
know failure
events because yeah there's no width
involved and another interesting feature
of the proof is it it it introduces and
analyzes a canonical decision tree
associated with an entire you know depth
D formula instead of just depth to
formula okay I mean it's it's a sort of
horrible mess just to say exactly what
this is but right so right so the open
question is to remove this regular in at
each depth yeah not across just in each
yeah okay and then okay so okay so we
gets four regular AC zero form as we get
the stronger stronger algorithm and so
on I wanted to mention that yeah just to
mention so this improvement to the to
the I M piece at algorithm for regular
formulas actually leads to something new
so we get improved sharp side algorithm
for the quantified boolean formula
satisfiability problems okay I stayed
here but I want to let me just loss over
it in the interest of time because I
want to get to some more more
interesting stuff right so this open
problem another interesting question I'd
like to propose is so here's another
let's call the conjecture suppose I have
n boolean functions which are lambda
critical is the and of those functions
well necessarily order lambda times log
M critical and if so then this would
imply the result on regular AC zero
formulas and moreover do it an
interesting you know and sort of most
semantic induction hypothesis as opposed
to syntactic one I think would be very
it'd be very neat if one could show this
and another question so we noticed that
lambda criticality implies lambda degree
criticality you know is the converse
true
so blamed a degree critical comply order
lambda critical
so there's maybe seven minutes left and
I just wanted to give you a sort of
impressionistic tour of some other
switching limos out there I mean we've
been talking an awful lot about the
period of restriction which in some
sense isn't a very interesting random
restriction so yeah let me mention
briefly some other things okay well so
you can you can take exactly M stars
that's not very interesting
you can bias you know you can buy us the
ones in the zeros okay and you get
something maybe more interesting
switching lemma due to beam is a sort of
quick switching level so you have n
choose two variables representing the
potential edges in an end vertex graph
and we're going to the Stars are going
to form the edges of a clique on a peer
and Ahmet of vertices and the non stars
are set to one with some probability Q
and okay you can prove some switching
lemma for these kind of restrictions
using similar kind of razz broth style
arguments you get some bound of this
form then the point is you can use this
to prove lower bounds for the k-clique
function even average case click K click
function the bound you get are of this
form you have this sort of size that
depth trade-off and you know using a
switching lemma in the standard way you
get this dependence on D so this is
something I was able to remove for
constant depths but it takes
it's not about proving new switching
lemmas there but rather you find you
know finding new ways to use the
switching my mouth okay so there's this
very nice survey article of beam
switching I'm a primer which gives you
know my count of all these different
interesting restrictions so but what I
wanted to get to and in the end just to
show you some nice pictures mainly is to
discuss a recent breakthrough of Johann
hosta and for ac0 Frager so these are
restrictions for site and grades so so
here talking about proof complexity so a
c0 Frigga
all you need to know is it's a proof
system whether the lines of the proof or
depth da c 0 formulas it's some
generalization of resolution which you
could view as
that for one fragrant and the point is
that for the lower bounds that were
known here or you know we're until
recently much weaker than what we knew
for AC zero circuits so the sort of
strongest bounds from the nineties were
of the form exponential an end to the
one over exponential in D so instead of
1 over D we had this exponential decay
here so much worse than what we knew for
AC zero circuits so in a in a paper a
few years ago with guys
so we proved some other incomparable
mild lower bound but which introduced a
new approach for this citing
contradictions on expander grass using
random projections and then whereas we
got very mild the quantitative lower
bound so you know the right way to do
this and dot you know bounce which are
almost as strong as we know in the AC
zero setting for the seitan
contradiction on grids so let me tell
you about this lemma that he he
introduces here
ok so we're considering an N by n
toroidal grid so just a for regular
toroidal grid and let's let's fix end to
be odd an odd number and this seitan
contradiction for this for the graph is
going to be an unsatisfiable for DN a--
formula where we have a variable x e for
each edge e in the in the graph and we
have clauses which are saying that the
parity so for every four edges which
meet at a common vertex their parity is
odd it's not hard to show that the
because we have an odd number of
vertices over all that this is an
unsatisfiable DNF formula so we're just
in what's the complexity of refuting
this and deathy Frager okay so right so
here we have the the graph and here's a
natural approach to try for a random
random restriction so i want to reduce
an n by n grid to an L by L grid and
here's the first thing you would try you
pick L rows and columns uniformly at
random okay
and now we're going to for all of the
blue edges so that so the red edges here
gonna be are gonna somehow correspond to
the edges in the L by L grid for all the
other edges in our graph we're going to
set them uniformly at random to 0 or 1
in a in a way that doesn't violate any
of these parity constraints okay so
we're just picking a point in some
affine set and then so along these what
I'll call super edges these red super
edges here we're going to introduce a
new variable and then you'll note that
the incoming constraints you know on
either side here are sort of in order
for this variable to be satisfied if
this one is y then this has to be
negation of Y and so on so we get a
projection of these four variables onto
either Y or not Y so this is a very
natural way of defining a projection
from an M by n grid to an L by L grid
and you know so Kenny one proved a
switching lemma for this kind of random
projection okay and unfortunately one
doesn't get a useful switching lemma
this way just to say very briefly why I
have a useful switching lemma you know
we need this kind of tail bounds that
for any if I take any K variables in the
in the grid X variables then the
probability that they projected distinct
Y variables should decay like epsilon to
the K for some and the problem is that
this won't hold because if we consider
four variables which lie all on a row
then okay well there's some probability
that they're all killed but you note
that if one of them survived so you know
if one of them survives then it's it's
likely that they all survived and if
they're sort of evenly spaced it's very
likely that they all map to distinct
variables okay so we don't get an
exponential bound here that's sort of
what you intuitively what you need write
something if this survives so right so
hot stud gets around this very by in a
very neat way okay so he takes a
different random embedding okay what it
ends up looking like is something like
this you pick your you pick your the
points of your L by L grid but they're
not going to be all you know they're not
gonna be nicely lined up
and there's a certain way that you
attach them by my sort of paths which
may have four turns in them this is
giving a topological embedding of an L
by L grid and an N by n grid and you
know you can project to a projection of
sight and instances in the natural way
you know this these random random
projections satisfy the key criterion
that we that we desire epsilon will be
something like a root right I mean so
intuitively why is this holding you know
if you have two if you have two guys
which are far apart then this
probability that they both survive is
sort of independent and if they're close
together then the probability that they
survive is correlated but then again
they're likely to project to the same
variable okay so the you know
unfortunate this kind of restriction is
very hard to analyze with is wait wait
or do you know what this directly so the
hostiles proof has two steps so first he
defines switching them of which with
respect to a preliminary partial
restriction which has more independence
and then you know this is the switching
limo which reduces the depth of each
formula and the ac0 Frigga proof and
then there's a clean-up step which
arbitrarily completes the partial
restriction to a restriction of the form
that I showed okay and and you know you
need this for the purposes of induction
so just here's a picture I mean the
partial restriction looks something like
this you have many more centers than you
actually need
and then right and then in the you sort
of have crossing paths here which
introduces some complications but and
then you have a clean-up step you know
some subset of these centers will be the
chosen centers and this will form the
topological embedding
so so to conclude I just wanted to
mention another open problem in this
area so to come up with a depth
hierarchy theorem for AC zero Freya this
is this is you know a natural problem
which which is open so in other words
find a family of unsatisfiable DNF
formulas with you know polynomial size
depth D plus 1 reputations but which
require exponential size depth D
refutations now just to mention so in
the in the circuit setting we we have
such deep hierarchy theorems they
involve these Reed ones sips or
functions that's a very obvious choice
of function that you use but in the
proof complexity setting it's unclear
what even the right unsatisfiable DNFs
should be so there's another question i
wanted to that would be fine so yeah no
yes nothing nothing is nothing is known
I mean you could get a like with hostage
result you could get like a
quasi-polynomial separation but not not
as exponential one there's a result of
cryo check which so it's key here that
the family of formula so they don't know
if it would be still interesting if if
they weren't DNFs but some constant
depth but if your formulas are allowed
to have depth D or something like minus
1 then there are examples of young cryo
check I mean in some sense the the sips
or functions are comparing you you know
they're they're not expressible as DNA
exactly yeah that's right I mean you
don't have that there so you're right
it's like it's hard to think what
exactly are the right yeah you take a
very solution to aces you a favor
yeah they're probably yeah yo then right
yet that
we
it gets weak ditchin whole principle for
example best bossy all over the place
constant death
other questions
that's the manager
[Applause]